bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 week-end
l'émission consacrée à vos loisirs et
vos idées de sortie alors ce weekend de
les refuges SPA des Yvelines ouvre leurs
portes un événement Anne parenté nous y
reviendrons tout à l'heure mais avant
cela place à notre premier invité il est
venu nous parler de la Fête de la Nature
alors à l'occasion de la Fête de la
Nature ce week-end de nombreuses
animations sont proposées dans tout le
département des Yvelines coup de
projecteurs sur le programme à
Guyancourt avec notre invité bonjour
Alors Mathieu deflores se vous êtes
chargé d'animation à l'office pour les
insectes et leur environnement une
association basée à Guyancourt et ce
dimanche 24 mai donc de 10h à 18h vous
donnez rendez-vous aux étangs de la
lumière au bord de l'eau que sera-t-il
proposé aux visiteurs alors cette année
c'est la première année qu'on propose
une journée portes ouvertes uniquement
sur l'espace nature des Val d'Or en fait
depuis pas mal d'années ont proposé une
journée portes ouvertes de la maison des
insectes donc qui est sur sur le campus
de l'ancien INRA et en fait cette année
on a décidé d'ouvrir uniquement l'Espace
Nature du Val d'Or c'est au niveau des
étangs de la minière donc beaucoup de
gens connaissent dans la région c'est un
étang qui a été clos depuis les années
70 qui est qui appartient à l'ONF et qui
est géré par l'OPI et l' ONF pour faire
essentiellement des animations nature
pour découvrir les petites bêtes donc on
a vraiment conçu
on gère l'espace pour les petites bêtes
essentiellement et pour les animations
sur les petites bêtes alors au programme
on a vu qu'il y avait des ateliers quel
type d'ateliers par exemple alors ça va
être une journée assez complète on va
avoir des ateliers effectivement sur
inscription alors le jour J qui vont
vous permettre d'aller à la découverte
des petits insectes aquatiques
ou alors
j'ai pu le détail de tous les ateliers
enfin il y en a pas mal plastiques
simplement pour les enfants
fabriquer ça son insecte en matériaux
naturels on va avoir des sorties nature
pour aller découvrir les insectes
directement dans la nature alors c'est
assez on est à deux minutes de
Versailles mais on est vraiment immergé
en pleine nature en fait
alors sur
vraiment sur l'aspect sorti nature il y
a énormément d'insectes aquatiques qu'on
va pouvoir voir la thématique de la Fête
de la Nature cette année c'est au bord
de l'eau et donc on a évidemment ayant
un espace naturel plutôt humide
d'ailleurs si vous venez prévoyez de
bonnes chaussures
et bien forcément on va parler beaucoup
des insectes aquatiques mais au noir
aussi une salle pas mal de gens
connaissent l'OPI notamment pour son
ancienne salle d'exposition avec des
insectes tropicaux et en fait on va
recréer une sorte de salle d'exposition
dans l'espace nature du Val d'Or vous
pourrez aussi retrouver les insectes
tropicaux des phasmes des papillons des
criquets des sauterelles etc et les
libellules bien sûr qu'on va voir mais
alors là pour le coup on pourra aller à
l'achat entre guillemets à la chasse aux
libellules c'est les capturer puis après
les relâcher les identifier voilà c'est
extrêmement varié très bien alors l'op
suivi donc l'antenne des insectes à
réaliser une bande-annonce de cet
événement je vous propose tout de suite
un extrait
bonjour Stéphanie de quoi vas-tu nous
parler aujourd'hui c'est
bientôt grande journée au bord de l'eau
en compagnie des insectes et c'est quand
le dimanche 24 mai 2015 oui c'est où à
l'Espace Nature
pour les enfants
atelier
un pique-nique
n'oublie pas votre pique-nique et vous
marche au 24
voilà donc ne pas oublier le pique-nique
et vous l'avez dit les bonnes chaussures
demain car le tableau une balade autour
du Val d'Or est proposée c'est bien ça
oui on va avoir donc dans les sorties on
va avoir une balade autour du Val d'Or
là il y a des endroits qui sont vraiment
des prairies humides donc si vous venez
en sandalettes vous risquez d'avoir les
pieds mouillés très bien alors la
recette de la nature en tête ça aurait
été un petit moment elle existe depuis
un bout de temps depuis 2007 elle se
déroule donc au niveau vraiment national
partout quel est l'objectif finalement
de cette fête alors l'objectif c'est
vraiment de d'essayer de reconnecter les
gens à la nature qui les entoure c'est à
dire que pour le coup c'est un constat
qui est assez large les gens se coupent
beaucoup de plus en plus de la nature
vivent essentiellement dans les villes
là le but c'est vraiment de dire aux
gens venez l'en nature venez rencontrer
des gens qui la connaissent et venez au
pied de chez vous ou alors dans un
espace naturel exceptionnel c'est
vraiment on peut avoir tous les cas de
figure on peut aller dans un parc
national mais on peut aussi aller faire
une sortie dans un parc au beau milieu
de la ville mais venez découvrir ce qui
vous entoure la biodiversité
la nature qui vous entoure c'est
vraiment le principe est toujours avec
une volonté que toutes les
manifestations sont gratuites
très bien justement cette cette fête se
déroule toujours à proximité du 22 mai
qui est justement la journée apparemment
internationale de la biodiversité
on va peut-être en profiter pour revenir
sur les actions de l'OPI donc l'office
pour les insectes et leur environnement
qu'est-ce que c'est alors c'est une
association donc on a été créé en 1969
donc c'est une association qui est assez
ancienne
on a une association nationale
c'est-à-dire on est ancré au niveau
local mais on a une action véritablement
au niveau national donc on a des actions
extrêmement variées ça passe de la
pédagogie on va beaucoup dans les écoles
faire de la pédagogie sur les insectes
les sorties nature etc on a les
publications aussi on publie une revue
tous les trimestres qui s'appelle
insectes qui est donc la seule revue en
France qui soit une revue spécialisée
mais pas une revue de spécialiste qui
est vraiment une revue que toute
personne intéressée peut tout à fait
lire sans problème alors les articles un
peu plus poussés d'autres qui sont très
grand public
on a aussi un peu l'étude qui est très
important
notamment dans ce pôle étude on a aussi
un pôle plan nationaux d'action donc on
a lancé les plans et on a lancé on a
animé les plans nationaux d'action en
faveur des eaux Donats c'est-à-dire des
libellules certaines espèces de
libellules de certains papillons et je
crois que c'est hier bon avant-hier
Ségolène Royal a annoncé donc le premier
plan national d'action en faveur des
polonisateurs sauvages qui s'appelle
France terre de pollinisateur c'est donc
le pic qui a été chargé de rédiger de
coordonner les travaux de différents
experts et qui a priori normalement
devrait bien être en charge de
l'animation de ce projet au niveau
national donc
exactement et les milieux surtout dans
lesquels on les étudie et les milieux
dans lesquels ils vivent très bien on a
tendance
à l'étang
des mythmiques le temps s'annonce
Clément normalement exactement parfait
voilà vous attendez du monde ben écoutez
c'est la première fois qu'on fait cette
formule là mais on va dire que sur une
journée à la maison des insectes une
bonne journée on accueille à peu près
1200 1300 personnes donc sur une journée
comme ça je pense qu'on peut accueillir
un millier de personnes si il fait beau
quant à nous on continue cette édition
avec l'actualité des expositions du
weekend
l'hôtel de ville de Guyancourt fête les
20 ans de sa construction une sélection
des œuvres acquises par la ville au fil
des années est exposée au niveau de la
mezzanine depuis mercredi et ce jusqu'au
26 juin l'occasion pour les visiteurs de
découvrir la grande diversité de la
collection Sephora Namani et le
Christine fait partie des artistes
sélectionnés pour l'exposition proposée
du 20 mai au 26 juin en l'honneur des 20
ans de la mezzanine de l'hôtel de ville
de Guyancourt peintre professionnel sur
Guyancourt pendant 23 ans Christine nous
permet de découvrir grâce à ses
aquarelles ce à quoi ressemblait
l'église et l'ancienne mairie il y a 15
ans j'ai découvert Guyancourt mes
enfants étaient tout petits et je quand
je me suis promenée dans les environs
j'ai trouvé le charme le charme
extraordinaire de ce lieu j'aimais tout
de suite Guyancourt j'ai été très
heureuse d'ailleurs et j'ai eu envie de
faire beaucoup d'aquarelles à cette
époque sur Guyancourt que je faisais sur
place d'après nature et j'ai pensé que
ça leur les intéresserait d'avoir un
tableau qui a une quinzaine d'années et
qui me retrace justement les débuts de
l'installation des jeunes
ménages qui venaient à cette époque
parce que en été dans le domaine de la
Noël où je vivais c'était déjà le ménage
avec des petits enfants tout le monde se
connaissait et il y avait une
convivialité qui était formidable et
donc je pense que ça les intéressera
d'avoir un témoignage au fond historique
de
Guyancourt et de la mairie qui est quand
même qui a beaucoup évolué qui est
magnifique maintenant cette exposition a
fait l'objet préalable d'un inventaire
complet du patrimoine culturel de
Guyancourt une fois celui-ci recensé sur
les 76 œuvres disponibles 24 ont été
retenus par le comité de sélection
composé des différents services
culturels de la ville un inventaire a
été fait pour récolter et du coup
identifier toutes les oeuvres de la
ville donc nous avons
nous sommes allés dans tous les bureaux
mais également dans les équipements de
la ville pour pouvoir répertorier ses
œuvres et c'est à partir de là que nous
devons fait notre sélection c'était un
petit peu un choix en fonction de nos
goûts mais également en fonction des
techniques différentes donc ça a été
vraiment un choix très éclectique après
l'exposition les oeuvres retourneront
dans les bureaux les équipements
visibles au public et bientôt les écoles
pour que les habitants puissent en
profiter c'est aussi pour les personnes
qui du coup côtoie ses œuvres quotidien
une manière de rencontrer l'art donc de
s'habituer à l'art et peut-être de
visiter d'autres expositions de se
donner l'envie de découvrir la culture
et l'art la culture je pense que c'est
source de
réflexion sur ce de connaissances
sources de plaisir source d'ouverture je
pense que c'est fait partie des choses
importantes dans l'éducation
démocratiser la culture fait partie des
principaux enjeux de la ville de
Guyancourt qui s'engage chaque année
dans une politique d'acquisition
d'œuvres d'art importante
et en exposition toujours elle se
termine ce samedi 23 mai dernier jour
pour en profiter l'exposition fais ton
tri à la Maison de l'Environnement de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines recycler ses
déchets n'est pas toujours évident cette
exposition est justement le moyen d'en
savoir un peu plus comment et pourquoi
les recycler toutes les réponses samedi
de 14h à 18h l'entrée est libre du côté
de Magny-les-Hameaux la maison des
bonheurs présente l'exposition un
cabinet de curiosité des petites
peintures d'une grande artiste qui nous
plonge dans son univers sensible un
projet coordonné par la Communauté
d'Agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines là aussi
l'entrée libre
je vous le disais dans les titres les
sociétés protectrices des animaux des
Yvelines ouvre leur porte ce week-end
les trois refuges du département vous
attendent sans interruption de 10 heures
à 18h celui d'Orgeval dermerait près de
Rambouillet ainsi que celui de plaisir
et pour en parler avec nous en plateau
Marie-Laure Caron la responsable du
refuge de plaisir bonjour alors quel est
l'objectif de ces portes ouvertes alors
c'est de faire beaucoup plus de
publicités autour de notre association
pour faire on espère beaucoup plus
d'adoption puisque en fait voilà le but
de la SPA c'est quand même donc de
protéger mais aussi de trouver un foyer
à tous nos petits protégés très bien
alors à l'occasion cet événement a lancé
une nouvelle campagne de de publicité
justement en faveur de la SPA et de ses
portes ouvertes qui consiste un peu à
balayer les préjugés ce que peut nous en
dire un petit peu plus alors oui parce
que à la SPA nous avons de tout nous
avons aussi des animaux avec des
handicaps sur justement sur les fiches
de campagne on a un chat à Borne mais ça
n'empêche que ce sont quand même des
animaux très intéressants très
attachants et qui mérite eux aussi
d'avoir un foyer très bien lors de ces
portes ouvertes ce sera aussi justement
l'occasion de l'expliquer un peu le
fonctionnement des SPA aux visiteurs je
suppose alors on est on est on espère
que ça aura le succès habituel donc on
est vraiment concentré sur trouver
vraiment l'animal qui correspond à la
famille puisque le but premier de la SPA
c'est quand même justement de faire en
sorte que les personnes qui viennent
adopter trouvent l'animal qui leur
correspondent le mieux et refuge de
plaisir on y trouve des chiens des chats
uniquement alors on a aussi des rongeurs
parce que malheureusement les lapins les
rats sont aussi abandonnés donc on en a
aussi à l'adoption et comment ça se
passe si on souhaite adopter un animal
alors vous conseiller comment ça se
passe alors donc les personnes se
présentent au refuge donc on a aussi des
sites internet où vous avez tous nos
animaux qui sont mis sur le site et puis
on discute déjà donc les gens font déjà
un petit repère repérage pardon pour
pour voir un petit peu s'ils ont un coup
de cœur ou pas et puis tout les
collègues les agents animaliers sont là
pour enseigner au mieux pour je vous dis
trouver en fait l'animal qui correspond
le mieux parce que c'est vraiment une
question voilà il faut trouver l'animal
qui correspond au rythme de la famille
si vous êtes plutôt du genre calme
tranquille il faut éviter de prendre un
chien très dynamique parce que
malheureusement si vous n'arrivez pas à
lui donner ce dont il a besoin ça
malheureusement ça peut être un échec
donc mes collègues les collègues dans
les refuges sont là justement pour
essayer de trouver au mieux l'animal qui
correspond quel engagement ça implique
si on souhaite adopter un animal alors
il faut être très conscient que un
animal heureusement sa vie quand même
plusieurs années donc il faut il faut
voir au-delà de l'année de l'adoption il
faut penser aux vacances il faut penser
au budget aussi parce que
malheureusement ça aussi un coup quand
l'animal est malade ou rien que si pour
la nourriture donc il faut penser aussi
aux moyens de garde pour les vacances et
par contre en contrepartie enfin c'est
ça apporte énormément un animal et ça
c'est vraiment une bonne place dans le
foyer un bon animal de compagnie et le
coup
alors on demande une participation de
150 euros à l'adoption pour un chien en
sachant qu'ils sont
identifiés vaccinés stérilisés pour un
chat en demande d'une participation de
90 euros ils sont aussi vaccinés
identifiés testés et pour des rongeurs
éventuellement alors c'est participation
libre puisque voilà on ne met pas de
nous le but c'est que nos animaux nos
petits animaux nos petits rongeurs
trouvent aussi un foyer et alors qui
sont ces animaux que vous récupérez
c'est forcément des abandonnés des
oubliés comment vous les récupérez
finalement alors on a donc là par
exemple pour l'année 2014 on a fait
quand même rentrer 2500 animaux ou chien
et chats confondus donc ça fait beaucoup
on a à peu près la majorité vient
d'animaux ce sont des animaux qui
viennent de fourrière donc les animaux
qui ont été trouvés sur voie publique et
qui n'ont pas été récupérés par leurs
propriétaires et puis après on a les
abandons directs les gens qui viennent
directement au refuge pour pour nous les
confier et comment ça se passe du coup
après pour les leur donner un nom
comment vous décidez de l'identité après
de alors quand ils viennent quand ils
sont abandonnés ils ont déjà un nom par
contre quand ils viennent de fourrière
on ne le sait pas donc on leur trouve un
nom parce que c'est beaucoup plus
agréable pour tout le monde alors c'est
clair que quelquefois manque
d'imagination puisque malheureusement
beaucoup d'animaux qui rentrent mais
voilà et nous au moins enfin voilà on
leur donne un nom parce que chaque
animal a son importance et chaque animal
est unique donc on a besoin de
l'identifier comme ça très bien et alors
au refuge de plaisir est-ce que vous
avez des animaux qui sont là depuis très
longtemps qui deviennent très vieux
qu'on n'auraient pas à faire adopter
heureusement non puisqu'on a on fait on
fait de beaux placements maintenant oui
malheureusement des animaux qui restent
plus longtemps que d'autres derrière les
refuges il y a certains qui ont un an
deux ans de refuge
donc pour nous et c'est un peu dur parce
que rester autant d'années comme ça
derrière les barreaux c'est pas marrant
et heureusement on a des adoptants qui
viennent nous les adopter et alors les
bénévoles quotidiennement donnent de
leur temps pour ces animaux pour
améliorer leur bien-être qu'est-ce
qu'ils font alors on a on a la chance
d'avoir beaucoup de bénévoles donc les
bénévoles font énormément de choses on a
des bénévoles qui nous aident
concrètement au nettoyage puisque autant
d'animaux ça demande beaucoup de
beaucoup de nettoyage on a aussi des
bénévoles qui viennent promener nos
chiens nos chiens sont sortis toutes les
semaines en forêt et puis après on a
aussi les bénévoles qui nous aident
beaucoup justement par exemple pendant
les portes ouvertes on va tenir des
stands on va enfin c'est toute une
organisation donc les bénévoles nous
aident à cette organisation là on a
aussi on réalise tous les ans aussi un
canicross donc heureusement avec l'aide
des bénévoles voilà et puis les salariés
qui sont aussi très très motivés est-ce
que vous avez pour objectif de les
dresser ces animaux alors on a été la
SPA maintenant est formée par une par
Catherine Collignon une éducateur
comportementaliste donc on a on apprend
à éduquer les animaux donc oui on s'est
vraiment perfectionner là dessus et
notamment justement on donne des cours
d'éducation au refuge de plaisir puisque
voilà effectivement il y a certains
chiens qui ne vont pas s'habituer tout
de suite aux nouveaux foyers mais avec
du temps et de la patience et de bons
conseils heureusement ça marche et
quelle est la situation actuellement au
niveau des abandons est-ce que ça c'est
de plus en plus de moins en moins alors
malheureusement il y a toujours autant
d'abandons maintenant on essaie de
trouver justement un équilibre
heureusement avec les sorties puisque
c'est grâce aux personnes qui viennent
adopter que l'on peut sauver derrière
puisqu'il y a des abandons qui sont
urgents il y a des animaux qui sont pas
forcément bien traités dans certains
foyers donc là il faut absolument qu'on
les prenne rapidement et puis il y a
d'autres abandons où malheureusement les
gens n'ont pas le choix et c'est
vraiment un contre-cœur qui nous les
confie au refuge mais malheureusement
justement pour les accueillir il faut
qu'on ait la place pour les accueillir
donc grâce aux adoptants je suppose
qu'il y a un pic à chaque fois avant les
vacances c'est triste à dire mais alors
on a un peu plus d'abandon oui pendant
les vacances et c'est surtout que on
fait moins d'adoption donc on a moins de
place pour les entrées très bien bon je
le rappelle en tout cas ce week-end
samedi et dimanche donc les SPA des du
département ouvrent leurs portes de 10h
à 18h donc sans interruption celui de
plaisir se situe dans le bois de sainte
Apolline merci Marie-Laure Carron d'être
venu sur notre plateau on passe tout de
suite à la page sport de cette édition
allez on part le football américain à
présent une discipline qui se développe
doucement en France mais qui reste
encore assez marginal dans les Yvelines
une équipe fait office de référence en
la matière ce sont les Templiers des
lancers notre journaliste sportif Mickel
el midoro a osier il s'est glissé dans
la peau d'un joueur de l'équipe et à
tester pour vous cette discipline voici
un extrait alors comment on fait pour
être un bon receveur bah faut attraper
le ballon mais avant de l'attraper il
faut courir des tracés qui sont près
déterminés par la tactique donc le
coaterback c'est exactement ce que tu
vas faire comme comme tracer le nombre
de pas que tu fais dans telle direction
pour ensuite envoyer la balle au bon
endroit je te propose de passer à
l'exercice suivant poste suivant quator
bac
j'ai toujours le pied en avant en fait
parce que tous les tracés c'est avec des
pas
un petit peu de suspense quand même
retrouver l'intégralité de ce reportage
dans l'émission cette histoire mardi
prochain à 18h30 tout de suite
l'actualité cinéma
c'est le rendez-vous traditionnel avec
un professionnel du 7e art cette semaine
voici le coup de cœur de Cyril Adad du
cinéma de l'espace Philippe Noiret au
Clayes-sous-Bois
cette semaine notre coup de coeur est le
film croate bonté divine le jeu ne
prêtre Fabian arrive dans une petite île
au croate pour reprendre les rênes de la
paroisse préoccupé par le taux de
natalité médiocre il met en oeuvre un
plan pour inverser la tendance en
complicité avec le vendeur du kiosque
local pétard très religieux il se met à
percer tous les préservatifs vendus par
ce dernier à ce plan s'associe le
pharmacien marine qui remplace les
pilules contraceptives par des vitamines
très vite mariage et naissance se
multiplient un phénomène qui amène vite
sur l'île une foule de visiteurs
étrangers qui n'arrive pas à concevoir
tournez dans un village superbe au bord
de l'eau cette farce étonne autant
qu'elle détonne
cette comédie croate s'amuse des excès
de la religion et du nationalisme
exacerbé en faisant de quelques capotes
trouvées le sujet d'un film truculent le
film abat joliment les tabous en
choisissant le parti du burlesque
le film est soutenu par Charlie Hebdo et
Charb avait même réalisé le petit dessin
figurant sur la fiche
bonté divine est à découvrir cette
semaine à l'espace Philippe Moret
ce
samedi
courtoise Yann Lavabre pour en savoir
plus voici un extrait c'est une journée
consacrée à la marionnette du matin
jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin de l'après-midi
la marionnette pour tous les âges et
dans tous ses états donc on commence le
matin pour les plus jeunes spectateurs
et puis au fil des heures le spectateur
grandit
timide et bien c'est l'histoire d'un
petit garçon d'un petit garçon qui est
timide comme le titre l'indique et qui
va qui va apprendre à vaincre sa peur
pour réaliser ses rêves un très joli
spectacle de manipulation écrit par
Catherine Verlaguet et interprété par
Bénédicte Guichardon ce n'est pas de la
marionnette classique c'est de la
manipulation d'objets justement c'est
pour ça qu'on dit la marionnette dans
tous ses états la marionnette c'est
extrêmement variée c'est une discipline
qui se renouvelle sans cesse on est loin
du guignol d'antan ou la marionnette à
fil et là donc timide ça s'adresse aux
enfants à partir de 3 ans un spectacle à
découvrir en famille avec les parents
papi tu es prêt tu peux commencer à
parler
ma mère il s'appelait
j'imagine qu'elle était belle
je me souviens de son parfum
et pour retrouver l'intégralité de cette
chronique de Nicolas Gervais rendez-vous
sur le site internet de tvfils 78 dans
la dernière émission culturelle kiosque
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis un excellent weekend
sur TVfil